il y va pas viendront danser à travers
certaines quantité retrouve l'état
liquide tombe sur la place c'est au cœur
de ce bâtiment industriel de Montréal
que circa élabore de A à Z des
spiritueux fabriqués ici ce concept une
rareté au Québec et vu par l'équipe
comme un gage de qualité on se garantit
que ce qu'on met dans le corps des gens
c'est bien fait puis c'est fait que des
vraies herbes c'est pas des
aromaticiennes plutôt cette semaine le
centre sur les dépendances et l'usage de
substances a servi une mise en garde aux
Canadiens aucune quantité d'alcool ni
sécuritaire des recommandations plus
sévères qu'auparavant qui n’inquiète pas
Gizmo Sirois pour autant si le Québec
est plus en santé puis qu'on somme mieux
je pensais Win Win pour tout le monde ce
sont ceux qui distribuent en gros qui
est copront le plus à son avis
une vodka fait du grain à la bouteille à
45 50 dollars ou un jean à 45 dollars
bah déjà là on est un peu plus conscient
de ce qu'on voyait il y a quand même un
certain
mouvement sociétal qui fait que on peut
avoir du plaisir sans nécessairement
avoir une consommation d'alcool
ce changement d'habitude Valérian Roy
l'a vu venir il y a 10 ans il a fondé HP
d'une épée le premier jean sans alcool
fabriqué au Québec
les gens demandaient des
Virgin quelque chose puis c'était
simplement de faire le cocktail sans
l'alcool donc il manque un ingrédient
depuis il a considérablement élargi son
offre les boissons non alcoolisées on la
cote on pense aussi aux sportifs on
pense aux choix de santé on pense à des
raisons religieuses et que pense-t-il de
ces nouvelles recommandations
l'alcool c'est dangereux mais si c'est
consommé avec modération avec avec
intelligence je pense que il y a pas de
problème les dernières années ont été
particulièrement difficiles pour
l'industrie des bars et les pandémie
fermeture prolongée changement
d'habitude les établissements sont de
nouveau forcés de se réinventer ici qui
me permettra de Canada Montréal